bueno lo cierto es que en el cero del
partido republicano no todos son
abogados y no todos conocen la ley por
procesal
estadounidense ha habido más de 500
declaraciones juradas de personas y
testigos que han visto como observadores
republicanos no eran permitidos ver el
conteo y algún otro tipo de
irregularidad sobre todo el punto de
vista de lo que se conoce aquí como la
violación del igual protection' close
discriminaciones y de violaciones de
derechos civiles federales sin embargo
como usted bien ha explicado el inicio
pues los estados los tribunales
estatales tienen una ley procesal muy
diferente cada una y algunos de los
jueces están estimando la mayoría como
usted también dijo de que muchas de
estas pruebas pues han llegado tarde una
vez que ha terminado el conteo o que las
pruebas no venían directamente
proporcionada por los testigos y
entonces es por eso que los casos se
están desestimando no porque no haya
indicios de fraude o sobretodo de
irregularidades electorales
como decíamos en la presentación usted
es abogada se le están acabando las
opciones legales al actual presidente
donalson diría usted
lo que pasa es que hay una fecha límite
para presentar digamos estas demandas y
sobre todo certificar al ganador que
depende mucho de los estados algunos el
20 de noviembre otros el 23 y la fecha
final definitivamente para certificar el
ganador de las elecciones del 14 de
diciembre entonces nos estamos
aproximando a la fecha límite para que
los tribunales federales y sobre todo el
tribunal constitucional entiende que ha
habido una irregularidad y sobre todo
una cuestión de constitucionalidad que
llevase la las demandas a los tribunales
federales o al tribunal supremo correcto
pues muchísimas gracias maría ferrer
abogada y vicepresidenta de la asamblea
hispana republicana en miami florida por
su análisis estaremos muy pendientes
hembra 94 obviamente qué pasa de aquí al
14 de diciembre cuando por fin podremos
tener unos resultados oficiales de lo
que ha pasado en las elecciones de eeuu